all right so i'm going to be talking
about my journey to optimize a piece of
code i had written a few weeks ago
and
it plays into our ddos production
and it required to do
um
quite a few requests per second per core
because of our traffic um
this is not going to be about how we do
ddos protection um but this is going to
be about how i optimize the code
and
it mostly started
um
as my first project as a joint clockwise
so i was pretty excited
um it's a layer 70 us attack protection
um so
our goal is to not let botnet traffic
through our cloud and protect the origin
um just as a reminder layer 7 is the
application layer that's the http layer
um
and
the component i'm going to be focusing
on is
going to be about the heavy hitters spot
where where you identify heavy hitters
and and then you take some action
um
but before i get started with that um
this is one attack we saw recently uh
this is these are the user agent strings
and the number of requests they were
making from the same ip
so
either many clients behind the same ip
doing about the same number of requests
for everyone equally as you see
the distribution is pretty uniform which
is
suspicious and one of the user agent
strengths is uh
is not a well-known string that seems
incorrect
um
but what makes
well one way to be very certain about um
if it was not a human being is to see
the effort there
the referee actually um
that's a misspelling that happens to be
part of the spec because the unix
the dictionaries did not have the
correct spelling in them
or any spelling rather
um but so so as you guys are familiar
reference the
is a field in the http headers uh which
tells the
destination site what url you came from
and uh
so it should clearly be a url um
but as you can see the red ones are
junk and it was
uh probably the but that some probably
the bot that was written was not um
carefully done so that's junk anyway so
what's the architecture of this thing
um so we have lots of computers on the
edges and uh from all over the world
they send log data to our kafka cluster
uh that's millions of requests per
second
um and from that
cluster there are many different
consumers which consume data and process
it and take a different action so one of
them is the green list which is the gray
cluster
and
so it reads millions of requests per
second from kafka and
and then does some state coordination
with with one server
um
so
uh the request per second there i'm
calling that lambda and that's uh that's
something in our hands
um so the goal is to have that be
manageable
um so
one obvious way to have that is just
have a low
low lambda there um
so
so you keep track of say the top k
heavy hitters and and because anything
below that that is um nonsense so you
don't keep track of it uh that way you
reduce the coordination effort that's
required between different instances of
the grill lister
um
yeah and that was a design on on the
high level
um so
how do we find out the stream of
um incoming requests how do you find
like the who are the hitters
there's an algorithm called space-saving
algorithm which is a online algorithm
and um
um
it it happens to be
pretty good for most cases
and nfl go for that cloudflare had
already implemented this as a librarian
go so i was like
this is perfect um
let's just implement just use this and
see how it goes so i did that and
and uh so what's next then i had to
benchmark it so
um
how do you benchmark stuff you write a
benchmark test uh benchmark tests start
with uh bench uh
something and they take a testing.b
pointer to testing.b instance and um on
that instance you have b dot n and is
the number of times that's that test is
going to be run so you're supposed to
uh do what your benchmarking n times
and there's like more details on how to
do this um dave has a good blog post and
he's pretty awesome so
you should go read that if you want more
details um
what were the results it was doing at
about 3 000 requests per second per core
which was not gonna fly albert would
never let me put that in production not
keep up
um
uh so why was it slow uh so you do
you want to see what the cpu is doing
because it was uh the guerrillas over
cpu bound
so you can have it
you can use the same go test tool
to run the benchmark and output the cpu
profile for that it also creates a
binary for the test file which has the
relevant symbols to use people off to
map things out and where time is being
spent
so where was the time being spent
um
that's part of the output i got it was
all external code mostly ninety percent
but
and um
when the profiler does not understand
what kodi is being called it it calls it
external code
uh which
seemed pretty [ __ ] so
um
turns out it was because i was using a
virtual cpu i was using virtualbox and
they do not work well well at least i
couldn't figure out how to get the
virtualbox cpu to act like uh like
pretend to be his real cpu
um but
uh vmware does that that check mark at
the bottom of the field that says um
that promises to not break modern code
profiling applications um you need to
turn that on before you put the machine
and and
yeah
and then your profiler is gonna hurt
um so what did the real cpu profile say
um
so
most of the time was being spent in
copying memory around and um
that so that had to be optimized uh one
way to do that is to copy less of things
um
so pointers to strings
work way faster than copying the string
along
and and the space saving library was
keeping elements sorted uh using like an
array
and like a simple insert so it was it
was um
in worst case it's order n and if it
used like a priority queue it would be
worst case uh or to log in
just to visualize that
as
on the x x-axis as the input size grows
uh the y-axis is where the time is spent
um
the dark line is the log n and
that behaves much more friendly to you
than
other ran um
this is not a graph just to point out
this is not a graph from production this
is just a graph i built i i plotted off
ordering and
just the same
um
yeah so that was like one improvement
that could be done and and
the first pass of optimization involved
basically copying pointers and just
reducing the number of times you do copy
so that would uh
that turns out to be pretty awesome and
it
took me 275 requests per second per core
um so
i was really excited i was really happy
uh turns out the output was wrong
so
so uh
the processing rate was like approaching
workable it was not it workable and now
like i had this junk output
um so
why was that um
turns out
again this is not production
distribution but the distribution looks
like this it's like long tail they're
like a few heavy hitters and most of
them are like not hitting much
um so
so the uh i should have read the paper
properly that's one lesson i learned
always read your papers properly turns
out the streaming algorithm like most
streaming algorithms it out it was an
estimate algorithm and
for our distribution it just fails
so went back to the drawing bird
uh decided to do like a
like just
follow a naive approach
um why not just keep a map of all things
you see like and and swap things out
obviously
um
there is no second player it was just
just that and um
we
so here is when uh back of the envelope
calculations really help you should like
uh get in the habit to do that and um
don't say it's not going to exhaust all
our memory like not even close so it was
fine
so how do you find the top k from this
map then
um
the two
um
the first two things that come to mind
is like uh using sorting and soft things
uh most most implementations of sorting
things use quicksort and on average it
takes uh order and log n
or you could do quick select that finds
the kth value in the set it's
and that's order n
um
so again for visualization the dark is n
log n and the like third one is autoran
they do not deviate that much um it's
pretty okay uh but they do deviate
um
as the request as a set as as n
increases
so
ins
instead of implementing quicksort and
it's a quick select um i decided to just
use the sort and
for that you could reduce the data set
so if you go back to our distribution uh
they're like ultra low values which are
obviously uh there's
it's almost impossible that they are
going to contribute to be the top k
heavy hitter so you
uh
prune all them prune the map of ultra
low values so now you have a manageable
set of values and and you just use the
standard library start um
that
that actually was a correct
that
resulted in correct output and um it did
like 120 requests per second per core
so what's the next step next step was to
test in production obviously
um
but more like this
keyframe and test in production i
clearly did not test the image before
but run it in like a dark mode where you
have no side effects it's taking
production traffic you see how it's
doing
um but but you are not affecting the
rest of the system so
and which was done that was a good thing
i guess
um
it it wasn't fast enough i had not
accounted for like when the attacks
during peak loads the peak loads is even
higher and then um
uh it needed to be faster
so i could either go back and profile
things fix my benchmark test and um
um
and have the
benchmark produce output that's closer
to production
but the thing was already running and i
didn't have any
hooks in it to get like a cpu profile
while it's running
um
so
um hello perftop it's uh
perf is like uh it's a really nice
utility that's gonna perftop is gonna
give you like um
it's gonna display a top like output
it's gonna show you your hottest
functions in the process
and um you can find it on like linux
tools on like a debian
on debian and i think other things as
well obviously
um
so this is uh this is the final perf
stop i was lazy i didn't go back to do
with the old one but
in the old one what what produced
uh
the most time i spent in handling
garbage the garbage collector was
kicking in a lot and
the reason for that is because a bunch
of string manipulation was going on like
encoding information into like a string
and then decoding it when you are
analyzing it again
and
the reason i was doing that
was because you can't use like slices
and there were other data structures um
in s keys and maps
so
instead
i moved to like i moved to using a
struct that involved that could be used
as a key in a map and slices were
converted to arrays
that was like that was the biggest speed
up i
i experienced which did take me to 480
requests per second per core um it was
good enough um for multiple
uh
if the production load
is
it can handle multiple of the production
load which is um what you
should plan for anyway
um
i can i'm happy to
play around with the final map but
on the on the left side what you see is
which is a kafka go client which
produces a lot of garbage so if anyone
out there is looking for like a fun go
project you could probably do a
less garbage producing kafka library and
we'll be really happy
um but as you notice uh it's mostly all
the boxes are
there's no obvious big box except like
the futex i guess and um and
so it was no no low hanging fruit
anymore and it was good for production
so um that was good what were my
takeaways from this whole experience
start simple i did not start simple i
start like let's use a fancy algorithm
to not do that if you don't need to
benchmark things profile things verify
for correctness that's very important
tests are correct but like
you should always verify for correctness
eventually and back of the animal
calculations are always helpful
um
this was put in production um
and later we
did
did do some
changes to the algorithms we use some
luxury algorithms so
the
future xbox is much smaller now which
yep and
that's kind of it i think we're hiring
um you should join club fair
special thanks to albert who's here in
the audience you want to say hi
uh you should bug him with the tough
questions
um and stefan who also helped me he's
not here i think um
yeah that's it i'll take all these
questions and you can find me on the
internet
so what was the nature of the struct
that you ended up using as a cache key
translating uh an array or a slice i
guess into extract how did you do that
um what was the data structure that was
uh not
out of the box fit for and map
um it involved ips and other things and
ips are a
is basically behind the scenes a slice
and there are other some that's some of
the things you need to do like ipv6 all
the bottom
64 bits are not
they are free for the client to set so
you only want to keep track of the top
60 for higher 64 bits and things like
those so um instead we just had like
them at raw byte already
yeah
so
the compiler should these days actually
recognize if you do
a bite slice into a string as part of a
map
you should recognize that and not take
the overhead of actually making a string
on it
um
that was not kind of the only thing
though there was it was a string it was
like a custom encoding it had like bunch
of information i was creating strings
and yeah
it is a different story but if you just
have a white slice that you really want
to use as a map just go ahead and
convert it to a string as part of the
snap axis it should work just fine
any more questions
um
oh that was that good is no longer being
used i was like part of the other
library um it was to keep things sorted
and that was required as part of the
space saving algorithm
um yeah
uh
now we run it on the servers and we
actually take it from the real machine
yeah
what yeah do you see the uh real
hardware is comparable to what results
you're getting from the vm
uh
yeah they were like
huge boxes before that was spending a
lot of garbage even if it was like five
percent error it was too big enough to
fix
so that was fine
all right thank you everyone